hello welcome to the airplane canes yeah
this is a game missing the game before
that I didn't upload and I totally
screwed up in the post-mortem analysis
by somehow closing the whole software
the game was a draw and and it was it
was K it was ok I'm looking in I was
mostly clearly winning you do that due
to them and then throughout the game but
yeah we know the deal looked like one
second to check mail but yeah I just I
just accidentally close to software
because I somehow couldn't figure out
how to send a towel to my opponent which
it's not exactly difficult you have a
you have something and you have a buyer
you can enter it but it just it just
wasn't there and I was so irritated that
I there closer [ __ ] who software him um
anyway you didn't miss all that much and
so we have an English opening here with
with e3 and d3 this has been a pet line
of mine like 15-20 years ago I also is
scoring well with this these kind of
systems it's very young very sound solid
stuff I always hoped that black is
getting frisky and doing things like I
am doing things like g5 and weakening
himself it doesn't look like can see is
doing me that favored okay I'm taking
here and I'm trying to now expand in the
center this is often own interesting
with those slowish setups with c4 d33
this kind of pretty modest looking but
sometimes it has this coil spring kind
of quality that
all of a sudden I mean this is called
spring is a bit much but all of a sudden
I'm expanding all of a sudden and
actually feel like I'm getting the
better of it in the center yeah this son
he can take this pawn like take me to
and take me five there should be pretty
nice compensation i didn't really didn't
really think much about it may be
correctly i'm if you don't take it
you're probably suffering without having
any material compensation okay yourself
what's the deal I have to do something
with um with my bishop so I can just
play like normal stuff 94 so and then
yeah it doesn't really help all that
much I can pressurize okay let's do
something like this first double yeah
the bishop on g2 is an issue I have to
get some job for this piece either f1
and then like to see for something
something there or I need to get
something going with G form that can
also be an idea ok so here do I treat
the Knights there or not
I didn't want to do that originally okay
let's do this and try to avoid this d5
now is interesting i'm not sure if he
wants to allow 925 okay so this should f
10 yeah it feels unlikely that i'm
activating it with g-form currently or i
should have said it feels unlikely that
i will activated with this in the future
you
okay Maggie was before let's go for it
so if a 4 will be five it's not really a
big threat
you
yeah this is one of those situations
where you definitely have some
compensation but do you have an
advantage with white hmm let's start the
same at least I have easy ideas md5
would win the deef if I get to play b5
edwin on the deep on yeah I expected
this to happen so now i can think of
going back hem to to deform click first
or Martin a5 is also possible witnesses
I would like to be able to win the b5
point of possible ok I'll just go to
deform
Valentine shortly maybe get into a form
94 now i could actually put one look
here for flattening looks into well
isn't that a problem now if i take it
does not be five so and they have to
have a look at you have 60 and dropping
back and was it was awkward frame to
defend the position
okay take care and this this is
something very very well coordinated
black forfeits on time hmm yeah to let
that pawn sec I think he should be okay
really but it's not it's not so easy to
play in a practical game yeah the engine
likes likes black yeah I kind of a kind
of thought that it probably is not
something that the computer will be
totally enthusiastic about it wants to
play G for what I said some of those
ideas yeah did that just feel a little
bit too weird to me but it is kind of it
makes some sense so it looks at this and
no that's not bad yeah I was basically
am just piling up and try to build up
something something slow and it's always
enough I think for the porn but you
definitely are not better with white and
the engine says b6 ok and here the
computer wants to take it was a bit of a
gamble to be honest I thought okay I
should have something here but I didn't
really look closely at really look
closely and it seems I have activity I
can we do all kinds of active looking
things but it's not clear that I have
something for that yeah this this now is
a bit awkward and he has to always look
for those things those little threads
something like this is what the engine
is giving an 85 and yes this is probably
probably equal something like this it
can easily happen that there's a
position coming up where yeah and then
torn down but he is got all fours on the
world
conference ok I have to take that call
ok hope you enjoyed the game thanks for
watching